samsung vient de présenter ses nouveaux
smartphones pour l'année 2023 S23 S23
plus S23 ultra je voulais présenter il y
avait une différence au niveau des 22
entre les 22 S22+ et le S22 ultra cette
fois-ci sur semble tous la grosse
différence que vous allez avoir entre le
S23 et le S23 plus c'est la taille de
l'écran tandis que les 23 ultra raconte
une toute autre histoire il est vraiment
axé sur la productivité avec un stylet
le SPN et va beaucoup plus loin au
niveau de la photo sur les S23 yes 23
plus vous avez un capteur de 50
mégapixels pour votre grand angle un
ultra grand-angle de 12 mégapixels il y
a téléobjectif de 10 mégapixels avec un
zoom optique x 3 sans oublier une caméra
selfie de 12 mégapixels tandis que le
S23 ultra vachement plus loin avec un
grand angle de 200 mégapixels vous avez
également du très grand angle de 12
mégapixels et deux téléobjectif le
premier billet Méga Pixel avec un zoom
optique x 3 et le deuxième toujours 10
mégapixels avec un zoom optique x sans
oublier une caméra de selfie également
de 12 mégapixels et puis cette fois-ci
et ça c'est vraiment génial on retrouve
un processeur de Qualcomm le stade
dragon 8 gène 2 qui est basé sur
l'intelligence artificielle est-ce que
vous pourriez acheter un de ces
smartphones est-ce qu'il vous tente vous
font de l'oeil oui non quoi comment
marquer moi ça bien évidemment en
commentaire